[Music]
if you've got a grand or two lying
around to spend on a high-end VR headset
and PC great
but given the cables and pledges that
are still involved
chances are 2017 is not the year you're
gonna be shelling out to set up your
personal immersion cave instead you're
gonna be piggybacking on other people's
R&D budgets and turning VR into a night
out at places like Salt Lake City's
hyper reality theme park avoid visitors
can bus ghosts or explore temple ruins
that are mapped perfectly to their
real-world surroundings Kings for the
big screen
IMAX are planning a handful of the art
theaters and even headset maker HTC is
planning to put VR in movie theaters
cafes and arcades all over the globe
sure eventually virtual reality of gonna
sit alongside your home theater setup or
maybe even replace it for now though the
biggest investment you're gonna be
making in VR is buying tickets drones
are here and they promise to change the
world they'll beam the Internet
everywhere accelerate warfare transform
televised sports and of course hustle
your impulse buys to your doorstep
they're already bringing packages to
online shoppers in China and carrying
blood to hospitals in rural Rwanda but
in the u.s. the risks of adding drones
to already jam-packed airspace tried
30,000 flights a day have yielded strict
rules no flying beyond the operators
line-of-sight at night or over people
but federal regulators see those rules
as a starting point and they wrote them
with an eye toward evolution if you can
prove that bending the rules isn't crazy
dangerous the FAA is game to let you
experiment and maybe adjust its
regulations based on the results it's
already granted hundreds of waivers CNN
gets to fly over crowds HBO can film at
night and Google's project wing gets to
fly 20 drones at once the FAA is already
expected to rethink the no flying over
people thing in the next few months
more rule changes are likely to follow
know don't expect your Amazon package to
plop onto your doorstep just yet but you
should know that while federal
regulators are moving cautiously their
most definitely moving forward
[Music]
criminalizing drugs is as American as
doing them but the days of outright
prohibition are over as the prescription
opioid crisis has burned through the
suburbs and made a fiction more
relatable reframing drug abuse is a
public health problem rather than a
criminal one has prompted reform-minded
legislation from both parties and while
America holds prescription medications
at arm's length it embraces recreational
drugs eight states voted to legalize
weed in some form in the last election
bringing the total to 29 and researchers
are studying the drugs medicinal
applications loosening attitudes toward
illicit drugs aren't limited to weed
researchers are also testing
psychedelics for treating mental
disorders like PTSD while Donald Trump
has pledged to combat the opioid crisis
by improving access to treatment and
abuse to term pain killers his
appointees have also called for stricter
marijuana enforcement and drug
sentencing good luck with that such a
hard-line stance will run counter to
state reforms and the six billion dollar
marijuana industry
[Music]
for decades now the car has been tightly
linked to the American idea of who you
are it's a declaration of independence
you're rolling castle and it's about to
come crumbling down
thanks to five key tech trends that are
changing the way Americans move first
things first
yes self-driving cars are coming uber is
already running in Pittsburgh I Do's in
China
Volvo's headed for England and Sweden
it's just the beginning second whether
you're driving yourself or not you will
be watched
insurance companies are using smart dash
cams and tracking devices to adjust your
rates and with electric cars making gas
taxes obsolete states are trying out
mileage based taxation next on the list
you'll get a powerup and not just from
the increasingly impressive electrics
coming to market facing regulatory
pressure automakers are working to
squeeze more power out of less gasoline
this look at Nissan's insane and
insanely complex variable compression
engine which ring serious oomph
from a 2-liter turbo oh and don't expect
private transportation to stay that way
ride-sharing services are starting to
partner up with public transit agencies
in a bid to fill gaps in transportation
networks uber is already at work in
Summit New Jersey and more deals are
coming and finally robot trucks the
safety and economic benefits of turning
18 wheelers over to the computer are
easy to see and the shift is coming soon
uber self-driving truck outfit Auto has
already made the first commercial
delivery without a human in the driver's
seat hauling 50,000 Budweiser's across
Colorado so yeah technology is taking
the wheel sit back and enjoy the ride
[Music]
acts of God are on the rise
insurers now pay nearly four times as
much to policyholders hit by natural
disasters than they did in 1980 that's
because God has had a major assist from
fossil fueled industrialization with the
Paris climate agreement the world's
emitters sought to slash carbon across
the public and private sectors like the
u.s. clean power plan which targeted
coal in India is betting big on solar
the deal sends a clear signal to
companies invest in green business
models after Trump with elected more
than 360 companies signed a letter
urging him to uphold the agreement many
arguing to it anyway Google will reach
100% renewable energy in 2017 and
Facebook and Amazon that's following
suit aim to sway Trump from his anti
green stance with economic calculations
because it's essential for us
competitiveness o also saving the very
planet we call home
[Music]
you